this was the biggest demonstration by
vladimir putin's critics in years
tens of thousands of russians took to
the streets
sparked by the imprisonment of one man
an anger about social injustice
political repression and staggering
corruption at the heart of the kremlin
but the protests were violently crushed
by the police
since then the repression has escalated
as putin seeks to silence all dissent
eliminating political opponents
exploiting the court
and purging russia of free speech
the games are over
and repression is no longer about
prevention
it's now about elimination
alexei navalny has become the undisputed
leader of russia's opposition
it was his investigations into
government corruption that stirred
russia from political apathy
his film about putin's billion-dollar
secret palace on the black sea had 120
million views and was watched by at
least a quarter of the russian
population
[Music]
not only that he had a plan to
demonstrate just how much resistance
there was to putin's ruling party
attack
steve
in the regional elections in 2019 he
promoted a new smart voting project
rallying voters behind whichever
candidate had the best chance of ousting
the united russia representative
one goal of his smart voting was destroy
the monopoly
once you
have that opening that starts a chemical
reaction of politics and struggle within
the elites and he was right and you know
in several regions did happen he rightly
identified the weak spot and the kremlin
saw it as a major threat
at the same time a key pillar of putin's
popularity is weakening economic growth
since 2014 russia's gdp has dropped by
almost 30 percent and a fiscal crisis in
2014 sparked a sharp devaluation of the
ruble from which it's yet to recover
with vocal opposition on the rise and
the economy starting to slide putin
acted
prominent kremlin critic is in a coma
fighting for his life in a german
hospital these pictures show him being
stretched into an ambulance he was then
airlifted to berlin question is who did
this
when the attempt to assassinate navalny
failed he was thrown in jail
prompting the nationwide protests in
january
the games are over and repression is no
longer about prevention
it's now about elimination of threat
violetta grudeno ran navalny's
headquarters in mauramansk a port city
in the northwest
[Music]
the kremlin moved to crush his whole
movement
violetta's office and 36 others in
navalny's network were forced to close
after prosecutors labeled navalny's
anti-corruption foundation an extremist
organization
they applied the law retrospectively
meaning that anybody
who had ever been associated with that
organization should be treated as
extremists so effectively they've
equated naval in his organization
decided to stand as an independent
candidate in the local elections
[Music]
[Music]
a cycle of intimidation began
her headquarters were vandalized her
campaign staff were targeted and
intimidated with arrests and trumped up
charges of drug trafficking
and the authorities even found a way to
use the pandemic to disrupt violetta's
campaign
despite testing negatives she was
forcibly detained in a covert hospital
this meant she couldn't submit the
documents needed to stand as a candidate
the kremen is very versatile in using
different tactics to crush not just
political opposition
but to deal with any sources of
discontent or political dissidence they
have used covered very imaginatively
instead of actually saving russian lives
they've used it as a repressive measure
violetta was only released from the
hospital weeks later after going on an
eight-day hunger strike
following her release violetta was more
determined than ever
against all the odds she managed to
submit the papers that formally
registered her as a candidate
she'd managed to stay in the running
longer than the handful of other former
navalny coordinators
who'd also tried to stand in elections
around the country
[Music]
just one day later she was called to a
meeting of the election commission
and
like navalny's allies before her she was
identified as a former member of an
extremist organization and banned from
standing
[Music]
in the 2021 state duma elections some
opposition deputies mainly running on
the communist party ticket
did manage to get onto the ballot
but the elections were rigged putin's
united russia won retaining a two-thirds
majority in parliament big enough to
enable putin to change the russian
constitution
and it wouldn't be the first time in
2020 he pushed through amendments that
will allow him to remain in office for
at least another 16 years
as a 2024 presidential election
approaches putin has a personal vested
interest in ensuring the opposition
cannot compete
putin is not in the position
to leave office anymore his power his
money his life
are all tied together
in that office in the kremlin uh if you
were to lose power the chance of him
retiring peacefully are very very slim
the chances of his crown is retaining
their ill-gotten wealth is close to zero
protecting putin's regime means ramping
up spending on police and security
forces
in 2020 one-tenth of the budget was
allocated to domestic security
you have this spiral of repression
the more it represses the more
discontent there is the more discontent
there is the more it needs to repress
the more money it gets
those who are charged face almost
certain conviction
in 2020 99.64
of those tried were found guilty
according to the world justice project
russia has consistently had more
government influence in its criminal
justice system than almost any other
country in the rule of law index
russia doesn't have an independent legal
system legal system is one of the belts
of
political power in russia russia doesn't
have the rule of law
it has the law of the ruler
in the aftermath of the january protests
more than 11 000 people were arrested
and 90 criminal cases were launched
some 200 journalists were harassed and
detained
[Music]
allah good nicobar is a student
journalist who's awaiting trial
[Music]
for mr
she participated in a video with three
friends which encouraged young people to
exercise their legal right to protest
[Music]
although the students complied with the
authority's request to take the film
down their homes were raided
they've spent months under house arrest
awaiting their day in court if convicted
the group could face up to three years
in prison
foreign
journalists who don't toe putin's line
can now be branded by the government as
foreign agents forced to include a
disclaimer with anything they publish or
broadcast this is a label which people
have to wear symbolically it's
humiliating it stigmatizes people it
makes them untouchable
is
journalist malchet
[Music]
worse is being branded an undesirable
organization
any cooperation with which is punishable
by several years in prison
so far dozens of organizations are on
the list the majority added in the past
two years
despite the clampdown many journalists
continue to fight
the number one of investigative
journalists the quality of their work is
unlike anything we've seen in the past
20 30 years the fact that
nove gazietta one of russia's oldest
newspapers and its editor dmitry muratif
were awarded the nobel peace prize is
partly a recognition of that
extraordinary determination to carry on
although tv news remains a stronghold
for putin spewing out constant
propaganda its popularity is being
challenged by the internet social media
and youtube
sure
[Music]
in the past five years the share of
traditional sources of information tv
radio newspapers has shrunk from 75 to
45
the share of online sources of
information has grown from 18 to 45
percent the kremlin is desperately
trying to regain control over that
information space it's
trying to force foreign platforms
particularly youtube
to censor content
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for opponents like violetta the pressure
to leave grows by the day
people are actively encouraged to leave
the country
out of sight out of mind
russia is experiencing its largest
political exodus since the 1970s
those who stay increasingly live and
dread
according to a poll by the levada center
the share of russia's population who
fear repression and state violence is at
an all-time high
and as for the rest putin will rely on
the other force that served him well
throughout his two-decade-long reign
apathy
people have jobs they have kids they
might not be in as good a financial
state as they were
10 years ago but they still in a lot
better financial and economic state than
there were 20 or 30 years ago so there
is a lot to lose
and there is a lot to risk
you can find more of our coverage on
russian repression by clicking on the
link and viewers in the uk can also
watch a full-length documentary on what
this repression means for members of the
opposition in russia on the itv hub
thank you for watching and please don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]